انا بحوزتي قصه بطله فتاه صغيره لكن تحمل
بداخلها انسانيه كبيره جدا تجاه الانسان
وتجاه الحيوانات همم وبالاخص الكلاب
الضاله يعني التي لا احد يقترث كيف تاكل
كيف تشرب اين ماواها كل هذه التفاصيل تهتم
بها الطفل الصغيره جيهان زهير تهتم ايضا
باسعاف الكلاب الجارحه والمرضى وكل ما يخص
او يتعلق بالكلاب من من لا يذكر قصه الرجل
الذي ورد في الحديث همم يعني السد به
العطش في الصحراء وكان بقربه كلب يلهث
وياكل همم الثرى من شده العطش قال الرجل
لقد بلغ هذا الكلب من العطش مثل ما كان قد
بلغ مني وسقي الكلب بخفه فغفر له لنا في
كل هذه القصص يعني حكايات وعظات
عبر تنضم الى جيهان همم مرحب بك يا جيهان
يسعد صباحك بالخير
انا جيهان زهير وانا عمري 12 سنه طيب يا
جيهان اول حاجه احكي لي حبك للكلاب وكيف
ذاته بتقضي يومك معك لبن عرفت انه معظم
وقتك انت بكون مع الكلاب من المدرسه لازم
تتطمن عليهم احكي لها تفاصيل لك انا لما
اجي نازله الصباح بدري لما اكون محشي
المدرسه لازم الدراسه اكل ومايا وليزا
برده ولما يجي الهرجه من المدرسه
المعاني دي من ودي دراز اه عمرها كم كده
يعني يكون
اها جيهان يعني الناس دائما ماخذه فكره
انه الكلاب الضاله هي شرسه عكس الكلاب
اللي بيكون الواحد مسؤول منها ومربيها في
البيت همم شنو بتوجه الناس دائما بالحته
بتاعه الكلاب الضاله
لكن ما بيغلبك لو انت بس وديتك الكلب مويه
ولا اديته وهكذا نعمل الكلام ده مع
حيوانات كعبه
انت فاهمه
الحيوانات او الكلاب
همم طبعا ولوف جدا في المشاهد يعني نادين
توضح الصور والمشاهد جيهان تقترب من
مجموعه كلاب همم صغار همم يعني همم هذه
الكلاب همم لا تعترض يعني عكس ما يحدث
دائما اي ام همم يعني كلبه لا لا لا تسمح
باحد لاحد ان يخترب من كلاب يعني وتصبح
شرسه للغايه لهذه همم الطفل او جيهان يعني
مقدرات رائعه جدا جيهان همم
مشاهد مع راس اسمها راس صحيح كيف بدي اطلق
عليه وما اسماء
المشاهد هذه العلاقه القويه النشات بين
جهاد ورز